spacci design
siete pronti a decollare
vi porto nello spazio nello spazio
cosmico lo spazio infinito
lo sconosciuto
questo si chiama overview effect e
l'ampliamento di coscienza che provano
gli astronauti dallo spazio guardando la
terra che appare piccolissima fragile
senza protezione ma anche senza confini
territoriali sociali non ci sono
differenze di razza e di religioni e fa
un bel salto di scala
perché il design che cos'è il design
di solito noi usiamo definire di design
un oggetto bello e ben fatto made in
italy e infatti siamo riconosciuti in
tutto il mondo per il design per la
creatività e per la bellezza italiana
però il design non è solo questo e molto
di più
design e visionario il design e
innovazione è un processo di innovazione
qui vi ho portato un progetto che ho
sviluppato con benedetto quaquero per
carini e brevetti che unisce due know
how molto diversi
una tecnologia
snow sound per tessuti acustici e la
pezzatura di una casa di moda di alta
gamma che oltre a generare una forma
sorprendente anche incrementato le
performance acustiche di questo oggetto
quindi mi sembrava un buon esempio per
spiegarvi come il design può parlare
linguaggi diversi e fare da ponte fra
scienza tecnologia e bellezza
che cosa può fare il design per lo
spazio il design si occupa dell'essere
umano
dei suoi bisogni a volte cerca di
anticiparli
e se un astronauta vivere un ambiente
confortevole
le sue performance aumentano e quindi e
questo va a impattare direttamente sul
successo dell'intera missione qui vedete
la stazione spaziale internazionale che
in questo momento orbita intorno alla
terra alla distanza di 400 chilometri
che non è neanche poi così tanto e gli
astronauti hanno il privilegio di vedere
nell'arco delle 24 ore
16 albe e 16 tramonti ogni 90 minuti
è veramente penso debba essere veramente
un'esperienza
straordinaria andiamo all'interno
l'interno è un po diverso
vivere all'interno della stazione
spaziale significa attraverso questa
transizione iniziare a provare
disorientamento e trasfigurazione
spaziale non c'è più un alto in basso
non c'è destra e sinistra se non per
convenzione si inizia a galleggiare
senza peso e iniziamo a roteare ca
quindi cambiano tutti i riferimenti
prospettici di percezione rispetto al
nostro corpo rispetto agli altri
all'ambiente
cambia il nostro corpo inizia a mutare
perché siamo in un ambiente
completamente diverso che ha delle leggi
che ci sono
sconosciute e che non fanno parte della
nostra esperienza quotidiana
quindi vivere nello spazio significa
ricominciare da capo con un nuovo corpo
e adattarsi alle leggi di un nuovo
ambiente
sono due le condizioni che differenziano
l'ambiente spaziale dalla terra e solo
principalmente il confinamento e la
microgravità il confinamento l'abbiamo
provato un po tutti durante il lock down
e quindi è una cosa che ci può essere
più familiare anche se in realtà qui
vivono in situazioni molto più estremi e
quindi parliamo di un ambiente che non
ha finestre in cui vivono per mesi
interi senza la possibilità di aprire
appunto una finestra per prendere area
in condizioni abbastanza
qui li vedete con i sacchi letto per
dormire
precarie e soprattutto
mancano tutti quegli stimoli naturali
magari noi non ci rendiamo conto però la
mancanza dell'area del vento del rumore
delle foglie la mancanza della luce
naturale che va poi alterare i ritmi
circadiani e provoca quindi depressione
stress per la mancanza di spazio e la
mancanza di privacy
la microgravità è sicuramente la
condizione più estrema che noi non
abbiamo la possibilità di provare questo
ma alterare la nostra fisiologia la
postura del corpo che cambia e diventa
molto più simile a quella assunta dal
corpo sott'acqua cambiano i nostri
processi cognitivi
cambia e alla forma del corpo perché i
liquidi si riversano nella parte alta
perché andiamo incontro a processi e
cambiamenti incredibili pensate che
nella prima settimana la colonna
vertebrale senza la pressione della
gravità aumenta fino a sette centimetri
questo è l'interno oggi del modulo
europeo columbus
vedete che un ambiente molto caotico
difficile da codificare
ci sono questi rec che ricoprono il
perimetro dei moduli che però non sono
neanche molto visibili con tutti i cavi
e gli equipaggiamenti che ci sono
guardando queste immagini mi sembra
abbastanza evidente che il design anche
se è una disciplina emergente può dare
un contributo interessante per
migliorare l'abitabilità di questo
spazio
questo è un progetto di una nuova
stazione spaziale che mi ha
commissionato thalesaleniaspace che per
la prima volta introduce un modulo
interamente dedicato all'intrattenimento
degli astronauti che questa è una grande
novità non so poi se verrà realizzato
quando comunque stiamo andando in una
direzione che privilegia anche il relax
e l'idea di riprodurre un ambiente che
abbia valori più domestici quindi
abbiamo lavorato molto sulla qualità
della luce il colore sulla
trasformazione degli arredi che possono
essere flessibili e cambiare
configurazione a secondo delle attività
e delle esigenze degli astronauti
qui vedete delle partizioni tessili e
delle cese long collassabili che possono
modificarsi e creare all'interno dello
spazio confine lato aperto anche momenti
di privacy
questo è l'esterno
perché tale se ci aveva chiesto anche di
lavorare sulla riconoscibilità esterna
della stazione perché fare un po di anni
ce ne saranno tante e quindi l'identità
di questo oggetto sarà anche importante
allora queste finestre che si alternano
e sembrano un po delle pietre
incastonate in un anello creano questa
idea di oggetto prezioso che naviga
nello spazio
progettare per lo spazio richiede una
grandissima capacità di previsione duro
per immaginare come si comporterà un
oggetto nello spazio come verrà usato in
che modo come si relazionerà con
l'ambiente circostante
proprio perché non fa parte della nostra
esperienza quotidiana quindi un
progettista deve immaginare tutte queste
cose io ho creato una metodologia
specifica che ho chiamato proprio design
dell'uso e del gesto e che insegno ai
miei studenti alla scuola del design del
politecnico di milano il corso spessori
spira con il semplice gesto di prendere
uno spicchio di un limone di un arancio
ha suggerito per esempio questo progetto
di un nuovo packaging edibile
un'altra cosa che insegniamo ai nostri
studenti e interpretare la microgravità
come un vantaggio e non considerarlo un
limite e quindi per esempio degustare
del vino attraverso un anello sfruttando
la capillarità a dei liquidi e anche la
maggior densità il micro per a vita
qui siamo in tales alenia space alla
presentazione finale di progetti che
riguardavano la stazione cheese lunare
getaway che sarà la prossima che
orbiterà intorno alla luna
ci tengo a dire che i nostri progetti
non sono solo dei bei disegni
noi lavoriamo con aziende reali noi
realizziamo anche spin off e spinning
che vuol dire trasferimenti di
tecnologie buone pratiche dalla terra lo
spazio e viceversa e soprattutto quello
che cerchiamo di fare è coinvolgere
anche aziende del design dei nostri
progetti
sottolineo che questo è l'unico corso al
mondo di architettura e design spaziale
che è supportato dall agenzia spaziale
europea che ogni anno con esperti e
scienziati definisce insieme a noi le
tematiche che sono più strategiche e in
accordo con i programmi di esplorazione
interplanetaria
non ci occupiamo solo di progettare
habitat extraterrestri oggetti
equipaggiamenti ma progettiamo anche
esperienze qui vedete un drone che
permette a questo turista spaziale di
farsi si chiama proprio space work una
passeggiata spaziale in tutta libertà
senza ancoraggi in sicurezza perché il
drone lo segue e poi lo abbraccia e se
lo riporta all'interno della stazione
quando ha finito il suo giro
questo progetto mi permette di
evidenziare il primo trasferimento
di progettualità dalla sua azione a
terra quindi questa applicazione è che
tra l'altro non l'ho detto ma in questo
caso l'azienda e dainese quindi abbiamo
sviluppato con loro questo tipo di
equipaggiamenti può servire benissimo
anche per supportare
quei sott'acqua
questo è l'inverso quindi spinning
le protesi di pistorius se applicate
sulla luna che è un sesto di gravità
possono aumentare la velocità e far fare
gli astronauti dei grandi balzi
un altra ispirazione in questo caso è il
colore e di giapponese che è una parola
intraducibile in italiano e che
significa più o meno la luce che filtra
dalle foglie e genera un certo tipo di
atmosfera quindi applicata all'interno
della stazione spaziale internazionale e
noi ci siamo immaginati con foscarini
l'idea di avere delle proiezioni
luminose che possano ripercorrere e
ridefinire quindi le varie fasi del
giorno e della notte e aiutare anche gli
astronauti a bilanciare i ritmi
circadiani
ci siamo occupati anche di fitness e
microgravità questi progetti sviluppati
con technogym in cui abbiamo voluto
cercare di riproporre sport e terrestri
all'interno della stazione microgravità
qui ci siamo ispirati ovviamente ai
movimenti degli acrobati e che possono
generare sport anche in coppia o di
gruppo e questo è molto importante
perché
gli astronauti per andare incontro
migliorare la decalcificazione ossea e
la perdita di massa muscolare sono
obbligati a fare di versione di
esercizio fisico al giorno e quindi è
importante creare e proporre anche degli
esercizi che siano divertenti
qui vedete delle partizioni tessili sono
degli schermi interattivi che permettono
di nascondere tutto quel caos che avete
visto prima e quindi creare
un po di ordine all'interno
dell'ambiente della stazione
abbiamo lavorato anche con virgin
galattiche ci ha chiesto di creare un
hotel sperimentando varie forme di
accoglienza e benessere e con jacuzzi in
cui ci siamo divertiti a verificare come
potesse assumere l'acqua forme diverse
densità diverse
e naturalmente in una esperienza di
accoglienza e benessere non poteva
mancare il cibo e quindi con barillà
abbiamo lavorato per un'esperienza di
degustazione di cibo e vino in cui la
pasta ovviamente stampata 3d e può
contenere è un oggetto strutturale che
può contenere delle salse con tutte le
sostanze nutritive necessarie
concludo questa presentazione con
un'astronave che sta andando verso marte
che sarà la prossima meta dopo la luna
perché è un corso di design spaziale
perché
perché lo spazio in cui era sempre di
più nella nostra vita di tutti i giorni
le prossime generazioni avranno il
privilegio di esplorare visitare altri
spazi e il design ha un grande ruolo e
può essere un vettore di innovazione e
proprio perché come dicevo all'inizio
parla linguaggi diversi e fa da ponte
fra scienza tecnologia e bellezza
grazie
[Applauso]